un débat déchire les algues vertes est
encore plus que la course à la direction
du parti conservateur qui va déterminer
pourtant qui sera leur prochain premier
ministre
ce sont les nouveaux modèles de plaques
d'immatriculation proposée par le
gouvernement
le slogan de la province wildrose
country disparaîtrait un débat qui
rappelle des souvenirs dans la belle
province
raphaël bobby au clair sur les routes de
l'alberta on les voit partout des
plaques d'immatriculation blanche rouge
et bleu qui pourrait bientôt disparaître
de la circulation
depuis quelques semaines le gouvernement
propose aux albertains de choisir entre
trois nouveaux modèles de plaques des
propositions qui ont toutes un point en
commun le slogan world blues country et
disparaît au profit de l'adresse du site
internet de la province le gouvernement
refuse de faire le lien
mais wilders est aussi le nom du
principal parti d'opposition
l'alberta n'est pas la première province
à changer l'inscription sur ses plaques
d'immatriculation en 1978 par exemple le
québec a troqué les mots la belle
province pour je me souviens cet
historien rappelle que l'initiative du
gouvernement du parti québécois n'avait
pas suscité énormément d'opposition mais
elle avait soulevé plusieurs questions
entre autres sur le sens de l'expression
utilisée le je me souviens sur la plaque
d'immatriculation
c'est aussi un geste pédagogique
composent c'est un geste identité mais
c'est un geste pédagogique
qu'est ce que ça veut dire de plus car
annoncer la nouvelle à propos de
nouvelle claque
cette boutique d'antiquités de moncton
est une mine d'or pour les
collectionneurs de plaques
d'immatriculation ici on constate que la
plupart des états et des provinces
d'amérique du nord ont des emblèmes ou
encore des slogans sur leurs plaques les
plus récentes les rues de la capitale
albertaine certaines critiques le design
des nouvelles plaques proposés et
plusieurs sont déçus par l'absence des
mots world growth 28 même s'ils sont
associés au nom d'une formation
politique
ces factions ne peut plus parler
f sa présence internet les plaques mais
c'est bien d'avoir une partition
l'alberta l'autre comme cet homme
s'intéresse peu aux débats après tout
même au pays du pétrole ce n'est pas
tout le monde qui se déplacent en
voiture ici a fait bouger au clair radio
canada elle monte